the third story is an interesting
reversal on all of this because
coca-cola
uh they were going fully woke now again
i don't think any of these capitalist
companies believe in woke i think they
they're doing it
to make more money it's the ultimate
capitalist move you got to kind of
respect the hustle there
but they're suddenly finding out that
when you go fully woke you're probably
breaking the law because you're racist
we've got some quotes here from reuters
a group of shareholders of coca-cola
company threatened legal
action against the company's board on
friday
unless it ends what they allege are
illegal policies that the company
adopted in january
to promote diversity among outside
lawyers the advocacy
group wrote to koch's board claiming the
diversity policy violates the civil
rights act
and the american the americans with
disabilities act so what is it exactly
that they were going to do
the post-millennial lays it out for us
on june 11th the american
civil rights project sent a warning
letter to coca-cola
alleging that the beverage corporation's
new diversity polity would require
contracted law firms to violate
anti-discrimination law the letter asks
the recently beleaguered company to
either
publicly retract the discriminatory
outside counsel policies
it announced in january or otherwise
provide access to the corporate records
related to the decision
of coca-cola's officers and directors to
adopt and retain those
illegal policies and this is the key
part the current
diversity policy in place at coca-cola
requires that the company
commit that at least 30 percent of the
build associate and partner time will be
from diverse attorneys
and of such amounts that at least half
will be from black attorneys so now they
could be in a lot of trouble
it's not just that drinking coke will
kill you because you're having like
i don't know how many teaspoons of sugar
or in a can of coke we do this every few
months it's a lot of sugar you're just
putting a lot of sugar
try some club soda if you need something
bubbly um
putting that aside um they were
basically saying yes
we are going to hire in this case
outside lawyers uh by the basis of the
color of their skin and at least 50
of them had to be black at the 30 i
guess you could maybe have some
latinos or something like that but in
essence we will discriminate
against white people we will
discriminate
against asian people and that is illegal
okay so now the board is in a lot of
trouble
so the lawyers are gonna have to figure
this thing out and and this is why you
should be hopeful about woke it is so
obviously racist it is so obviously
counter to equality
and account and um and the reverse of
all the principles that that most of us
have loved but maybe we forgot that we
had to keep fighting for them
but it's so obviously against all of
this stuff that eventually
not only will it overstep which it's
doing right now but then the legal
system i mean
maybe all we got left is the legal
system right like so the legislative
system
they're not going to fix anything the
democrats are in control of stuff right
now so they're not going to fix anything
at a state level we know that you know a
guy like desantis banning critical race
theory that that's working a little bit
but then basically let's get the
democrats and the socialists and the
marxists and the bernies and the hamas
caucus and all of them
let's get them to defend discrimination
because that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to make us
discriminate
i don't want to discriminate
discriminate against white people i
don't want to discriminate against asian
people
or black people or gay people which
reminds me
locals.com jobs we're hiring and i don't
give a flying [ __ ]
what color you are or what your gender
is or what sexuality you are
do you know how to do the job do you
work hard
are you a decent person you might get a
job with us and we're hiring in miami
right now so
jobs.locals.com and don't drink coke
anyway don't drink coke we're having a
big party here for my 45th on saturday
we
we got some coke because you just feel
like you should have a coke at a party
you should have
coca-cola that is i'm a little old for
the rest of that you know
uh but the point is uh you know some
people expect it but i was like
we really have to have this in the house
but we got a couple cans of coke by the
way there are 39
grams of sugar in a 12-ounce coca-cola
really google what that means it's an
awful lot of you just don't need that
much younger people